is my contention
that many of the major media platforms
in this country
are racist
and anti-semitic
and that's part of the problem we have
in this country they bring in
contributors and guests
if not have hosts and so forth
who spread this poison and they do it
constantly
and they do it under the cover of news
analysis
and of course it's none of those things
so let's begin here
you've heard me talk about the new york
times before
well
i want to give you a little bit
additional information the new york
times is supposed to be the gold
standard for the media
there have been at least three
tremendous books written on the subject
of the new york times and the holocaust
and its abject failure to cover it one
expert david s wyman the abandonment of
the jews america and the holocaust
1941-1945 another book
beyond belief
the american press and the coming of the
holocaust
1933-1945 professor deborah e lipstadt
third book buried by the times the
holocaust and america's most important
newspaper professor laura leff now why
am i getting into this information with
you because ladies and gentlemen
the press for the most part are corrupt
they're utterly corrupt i want to get
into a little bit of this with you emery
university professor deborah lipstead
her book
beyond belief
she saw the media self-censorship during
the holocaust as a broadly institutional
problem she wrote that the press bears a
great measure of responsibility for the
public skepticism and ignorance of the
scope of the wartime tragedy the nazi
mass murder of jews the public's doubts
were strengthened and possibly even
created by the manner in which the media
told the story
this relates to what goes on in our
country today how the media distort and
lie and spin
if the press did not help plant the
seeds of doubt in readers minds it did
little to eradicate them during the war
world war ii
during the war journalists frequently
said that the news of deportations and
executions did not come from
eyewitnesses who could personally
confirm what had happened and they as
journalists were obliged to treat it
skeptically this explanation is faulty
because much of the information came
from german statements germans weren't
hiding what they were doing broadcasts
and newspapers if anything these sources
would have been inclined to deny not
verify the news
neutral sources also affirmed the
reliability of reports
i mean there were reports in europe for
crying out loud moreover even when the
press did encounter witnesses it often
dismissed what they had to say because
they were not considered reliable or
impartial taking direct aim at the new
york times professor laura leff of
northeastern university formerly a
journalist meticulously scrutinized not
only the role of the media generally
during the holocaust but the new york
times in particular and she has written
extensively about quote how the new york
times failed in its coverage of the fate
of european jews from 1939 to 1942
in her book buried by the times she asks
what was it about prevailing press
standards and the policies and
personalities at the times that led the
nation's most important newspaper
discount one of the century's most
important news stories
and left then makes the damning
disclosure quote
the times judgment that the murder of
millions of jews was a relatively
unimportant story reverberated among
other journalists trying to assess the
news
among jewish groups trying to arouse
public opinion and among government
leaders trying to decide on an american
response
the times publisher arthur hayes
solzberger intentionally and repeatedly
buried news about the holocaust deep
within his paper or ignored it
altogether
she writes although the war was the
dominant news it need not have been and
was not the only front page news
the new york times printed between 12
and 15 front page stories every day
fewer than half of these typically
concerned the war
the times first story on the nazi
extermination campaign which described
it as the greatest mass slaughter in the
history appeared on page five
tacked onto the bottom of a column of
stories yet the deaths of other
civilians often fewer than a hundred
regularly appeared on the front page
indeed less research like that of wyman
and lipstick
found that the times and the media
overall withheld or buried much of what
they knew about the holocaust from the
american public
she wrote the way the press in general
and the times of particular presented
the facts played an important role in
creating the gap between information and
action the way the times and the rest of
the mass media told the story the
holocaust engendered no chance of
arousing public opinion the times never
treated the news of the holocaust as
important or at least as important to
say informing motorists to visit the
office of price administration if they
didn't have their automobile
registration number and state written on
their gasoline ration coupons a story
about that possible bureaucratic sniff
who appears on the front page on march 2
1944
the same day that the last voice from
the abyss was relegated to page four and
it goes on and on and it wasn't just the
holocaust that would be bad enough
it was also stalin
stalin walter durrante for 12 years
was the bureau chief in moscow
and during that period he was the bureau
chief once stalin was reigning it was
the bureau chief in 1932
when stalin ordered the extermination of
ukrainians genocide he cut off ukraine
he cut it off in every way imaginable to
starve the peasants there especially
because they would not join
these communes they would not allow
their land that had been passed on from
generation to generation to be taken by
the communists
and so he starred them to death
millions of them
and walter durandy reported in the front
page and other pages a news man for the
new york times
that it was a uh that it was a bad
harvest
that they were just going through
problems he was on stalin's payroll
stalin got him a girlfriend who whom he
impregnated stalia the best food he had
cars to travel
and there were british journalists who
actually went into the ukraine and saw
the horror of cannibalism and so forth
and they were disgusted and furious with
walter durandy who got a pulitzer prize
for his reporting by the way
and when you look at that and then when
you look at the new york times about a
half century ago 50 years ago
give or take the reporter in cuba
building up castro talking about how
castro had thousands and thousands of of
freedom fighters people who wanted
democracy supporting him when he had
about 12
maybe 20 at the most because he was
being defeated help build up castro and
then castro overthrows the government
there and of course he was a communist
and enemy of the united states he was a
surrogate of the soviet union
and even castro thanked the new york
times for the help that it received and
bring it to modern day
the new york times and russia collusion
it was the point of this beer pushing a
story that we now know was a lie from
beginning to end plaintiff by the
hillary clinton campaign in the dnc
planted by perkins cowie a democrat law
firm one of whose uh lawyers has since
been indicted another lawyer mark elias
who has dark money millions and millions
to influence the 2020 campaign and
future campaigns
and of course the obama administration
with the fbi and intelligence agencies
and the lies that they used to try and
destroy the trump candidacy and then the
trump presidency
anti-semitic
and it's not the only
organization that was and i said
that major news platforms in this
country
are also racist
you know the marxist left likes to throw
that word around racist to anybody who
supports the constitution
who loves this country who believes in
the flag and the national anthem
the united states military police
officers
these marxist reprobates throughout the
media throughout the democrat party and
of course
radicals who are part of the blm and
antifa movements
like to call everybody else racism that
there's systemic racism in this country
and so forth and so on there's not a
damn thing you can do about it other
than overthrow the country
jonathan k part
uh at msnbc
which is owned by comcast by the way
talking about the newly elected
soon-to-be lieutenant governor of
virginia
she's a black woman born in jamaica she
is a naturalized american citizen who
served in the marine corps as did her
husband
a small businesswoman and she was
elected the first woman the first black
lieutenant governor of virginia go
whiteness is a hell of a drug fear
worked and younkin won in a state
president biden won just last year by 10
points so what did all these racist
virginia voters do tuesday night in
addition to election all right let's
stop
all these racist virginia voters
what kind of a bigot is this he appears
regularly on msnbc and elsewhere
why would a major corporation comcast
which owns nbc and msnbc
put a bigot like this that's my opinion
on television to spread hate
the racist voters of virginia
you see how he dehumanizes every single
person who voted doesn't matter the race
they could be black they could be red
they could be brown they could be albino
whatever it is
if you voted the wrong way if you voted
against this american marxist agenda
you're obviously a racist
and this person is on television
constantly
can as governor they elected winsome
sears as lieutenant governor she will be
the first african-american woman to be
elected statewide in virginia history
writes the wall street journal
nice try but invoking the name of
lieutenant governor-elect winsome sears
doesn't prove my assertion wrong about
the role of race in the virginia
governor's election not in the least
look voting for someone black does not
grant absolution from racism or being
motivated by the racist
i don't think people voted
for winsome sears because they wanted
absolution about anything
i think they voted for winsome sears
because
she was a fantastic candidate
she has charisma
she's substantive she believes in the
country she believes in low taxes
she believes in martin luther king
and the content of one's character not
the color of their skin
that's why people voted for winsome
sears
has nothing to do with seeking
absolution go ahead
nowadays bull horns that politicians use
to play on racial fears for political
gain bull horns
bull horns that's the democrat party in
the deep south not the republican party
in modern day virginia
bull horns so listen to this
so the people of virginia vote in a a
black woman
a brilliant black woman an experienced
black woman a patriotic black woman and
we get lectured about absolution
and we get lectured about bull horns and
dog whistles
really
go ahead be clear
having some of your best friends be
black or family members be black or
dating or being married to someone black
or liking black music and culture is no
pass either also when you pass for what
pass for
what so if you're married to a black
person and you're not black
you're married to a black person and
you're not black because you love that
person
and that person loves you
because they're looking beyond
pigmentation they're looking into your
soul and your heart and your mind
you're as if you're one that's what
marriage is about
marriage isn't about oh look at this i
married a black person or look at this i
married a white person or a native
american or this side or the other
this is the sickening mindset
of these bigots these these american
marxists as far as i'm concerned go
granting folks black cards always
remember it's a joke blackness isn't
transferable
black cards
blackness isn't transferable
what in the hell is this buffoon talking
about
now we're never going to have a united
society we're never going to have a
society
where people look beyond race or faith
or anything else for that matter
as long as we have people with bull
horns
and dog whistles like jonathan k part
and he's certainly not alone
who are given these massive platforms
although not so massive msnbc but you
get my point
to spew their hate and in my view their
bigotry
this is an extraordinarily diverse
nation it's the most diverse nation on
the face of the earth it's the freest
nation on the face of the earth it's the
freest economic system on the face of
the earth you can do whatever you want
to do become whatever you want to become
get whatever kind of education you want
to get
it's up to you as an individual human
being but as you can hear jonathan k
part doesn't view you as individual
human beings he dehumanizes you
and he pushes his pablum as he does
which is very very dangerous and
evil new york times
msnbc and so many more
so many more of these platforms are
racist and anti-semitic hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else